hi my name is Peter Dalton and I am the
technical director for Blue Point games
today I'm gonna take you on a journey as
we walk through Shadow of the Colossus
and sort of look at blue points approach
to remastering games we spent a lot of
time trying to do the right thing for
Shadow of the Colossus we're not trying
to reinvent it while we call it a remake
it's more of an extension of itself and
so I really feel like we try to pay
attention to the environments make sure
that we have the same vibe the same
language and at the end of the player
takes away the same sort of experience
playing the original game on the ps2 it
left certain memories in my mind and as
I come back I feel like we've created
the game that I remember playing the
very first time as we started digging
into the original ps2 version of the
game we started learning more and more
about it and it was actually very
interesting to find out the depth to
which the original team went to provide
details within the game take for example
it wasn't until later in development
that I even realized that the number of
birds that are in a scene are actually
dictated by the colossi number that
you're on oh the stairs the stairs are
so fun when we started this game we
found that very early that the size of
the stairs did not really match great
proportions to human size steps and so
wander felt like he was a
mountain-climber trying to climb over
the top of things and so we reworked the
staircases
however the minute you rework the
staircases you know they used to go
there and then you rework them so
they're not as tall and now all of a
sudden you you've got twice as far to go
it took quite a bit to get aggro to
actually behave correctly going down a
flight of stairs so it didn't look like
he was trumping as he stopped down the
stairs
one of the biggest challenges throughout
this entire game was our streaming
system basically breaking up the world
so we would go through and break up
areas within here to say here is here's
one area and then over here is a
completely
different area that's sort of like a
Vista and then behind you we'd have the
cathedral and break those all up into
streaming regions so that we could bring
them in and out this area here was quite
interesting because not only do we have
Vista stuff but we also have a lot of
detail that's happening down here with
waterfalls in the water flow and then
there there's always aspects of the game
that are very its they're difficult to
change in fact you don't want to change
them you don't want to lose the magic of
the original like aggro is one of those
cases aggro his AI he purposely does not
always listen to you which at times you
can find frustrating you can whistle and
call for him and he doesn't care and we
wanted to make sure that we didn't break
any of those behaviors other things we
are very strategic about what we pull
over
take wanders poncho for example the
original version needed love and needed
work and was built on ps2 technology we
reworked the entire poncho using
modern-day physics but we also if you
look at it we kept the bone joints that
hang around Wanderers waste those are
actually the original ps2 coder that
coded those up we left those alone
because I don't know who that guy is but
he's amazing we spent so much time
looking at how we build rocks in fact
it's kind of a joke at Blue Point of of
how many man-hours can you actually
spend building rocks you would think
that you would run out of rocks to
create but no apparently every rock
needs to be unique we have very large
rock kits where we would build these
faces of these cliffs throughout the
entire game and then you know sort of
piece everything together and take other
rocks and sort of wedge them in together
to basically create these outlines one
of the things that we realized we spent
a lot of time even very early on in the
game looking at vegetation the grass
that's inside of the environments as we
started to just place the grass around
the front cathedral area we quickly
found that unless we hire three or four
armies there's no way we'll ever
complete this game so we actually use a
vegetation system
where art will go through and they will
paint the density of the grass that they
want inside of an environment and then
will on the GPU actually read that
texture back and actually spawn the
grass dynamically so they have control
to go in and say I want this to be sort
of a thinner area in the environment and
over here I want to make sure this is
thick long lush sort of grass one of the
other additions that we added to the
game how do we take wander this
character and how do we make him feel
more attached to the environment how do
we make him feel like he's aware of
everything around him and so we actually
added head tracking that did not exist
in the original ps2 version as the
camera moves and looks throughout the
environment wanders head will actually
move and sort of track and he'll also
track additional things from lizards
that you'll find inside of the
environment he'll notice them a lot of
times before the player does you'll see
wander looking over at the corner and
wonder what is he doing well he knows
that there's a lizard over there or
there's fruit or as we start to come up
on a colossi you'll start to pay
attention that stuff is coming
let's talk about real quick another part
of the of our engine that I feel like
worked really well for the ps4 version
of Shadow of the Colossus is I remember
playing the the very first version of
Shadow of the Colossus at e3 and
standing behind I was in a line of three
people standing behind them watching
them play and then getting my turn but
the number one thing that really stood
out to me was what was ii think the size
and scope of the Colossus and then the
FIR
I thought the fur was amazing I've never
seen anything really at that granularity
of fur on a character I'd mentioned
earlier that we also have a system for
dynamic vegetation where artists would
paint on to the environment well as we
started getting further and further into
the game we realized that this Colossus
has vegetation on him he's got plant
life actually on him that moves and not
only does it need to move but it needs
to sway as the wind blows but still stay
attached and look like it looked
realistic
as we started progressing you know as we
brought the game up initially we started
with the ps3 version of Shadow of the
Colossus that we remastered several
years ago that was based on the ps2
version and as we started building on it
as we started environments you know all
the environments would start with the
original geo of the original game and
then we would slowly go through and
replace everything as we went along
and then as you would get the art to
come in and all the pieces to start to
form you start to notice that there's
just the little details are lacking to
wander not paying attention to where I
look to you know the the bubbles that
are released as wander swims around and
as we started adding all those little
things it was great because it sort of
motivated the team to really see the
attention to detail that needed to put
into this title and encouraged us to
push further and here's a good example
not only you've got a combination here
there's basically two different layers
working where you've got the fur on the
Colossus right here that blends in very
nicely to the actual the dynamic
vegetation system here with all the
plants that are actually on him
the fur was was a big undertaking and I
like to think that it came out really
cool as you most likely seen as wander
sort of climbs up on top of the colossi
we would put collision capsules on
wanderer to push the the fur and stuff
away as you climb up it we wanted to
make sure that the fur felt very organic
- art would spend hours going through
and actually painting the fur to dictate
the stiffness the length of the fur in
addition to the color
[Music]
the blackness that gets spewed as you
destroy a weak point on a colossus we
spent so much time trying to figure out
what that should actually look like and
when I say we spend a lot of time trying
to figure out what it looked like it's
really going back to the ps2 version
looking at videos after videos after
videos of how it's used in the
environment and trying to determine what
was the exact motivation and what was
this style that they were trying to
achieve so we've done everything from it
should be smokey - it should be inky -
the combination that we sort of have
here in the final product on a lot of
our previous projects that we had worked
on any time we do a remaster we would go
and work within the original codebase
that the original team provided and so
we would work on adopting their
processes and their art pipeline and
everything and so if there was a
behavior we wanted to change we would go
directly into their code and make that
change with shadow initially as we
started looking at it as a remaster we
thought okay maybe we'll do the same
thing the original ps3 version is much
more along those lines of taking the
shadow codebase and basically modifying
the shadow codebase to bring it from the
ps2 to the ps3 as we started diving
deeper and deeper into the ps4 version
of Shadow it became apparent that there
was not enough systems and other things
in place within the original codebase so
while we could have went in and added
all of those pieces it really just did
not make sense and so we sort of spent a
lot of time structuring and defining
with areas of responsibility so we have
the original codebase that's running the
entire time which is responsible for
things such as the Colossus behavior
he's the one that just called out for
the Colossus to shoot his projectile to
building that on top of the Blue Point
engine that basically sits underneath
that provides all of the rendering
abilities it's responsible for the fur
the water the particle simulations and
then we'll also go in and we create
these like little hybrid systems like
take wander for example the shadow
version of the engine
as a version of shadow inside of it that
communicates with a version of it inside
of the Blue Point engine and most of the
logic and behavior is defined within
shadow but then the Blue Point engine
will add additional things such as The
Wanderers poncho is completely within
the bpe space two additional foot I K
that will add to the game to the head
tracking that we talked a little bit
earlier you know num we would go through
and make minor adjustments you know just
quality of life sort of improvements on
each one of these environments there's
ledges everywhere that wander can
basically grab onto to traverse the
environment you know so we would go
through and look at angles of approaches
wander was approaching edges and easing
some of those up to make the game maybe
a little less stringent well also
internally debating about not making the
game too easy there's so many details in
this game it is part of what makes it
such a beloved game in fact there's a
guide no bad who goes through and has
broken down the entire ps2 version of
the game we actually reference his
website like perhaps more than we
actually should to understand the inner
workings of the entire game you know to
each after each of the Colossus is
defeated the area that in the sky that
shows up above them this sort of you
know calls them out in the environment
sort of reminding you what you've done
inside of the world we actually flew him
out to the office towards the end of
development to give him a chance we
really wanted to have him sit down and
play it he was kind of excited when he
played the development build and we
showed him that we could access the
debug menu and fly behind the scenes of
all of the environment that was there
which was very similar to how he had
sort of split up and cracked the ps2
version but we don't allow that anymore
we're coming up here this is one of my
favorite areas of the entire game this
forest towards the last maybe two three
months of development we added photo
mode into the game and if there's one
thing I could do again I would make sure
to add photo mode so much earlier on in
development but it was really cool
because the art staff the engineering
team QA
all the departments would have these
little contests where they would go
through the gameplay and come up with
the most interesting of photo mode
situations that they could come up with
and I remember this area like with all
the different photo mode filters that
you can add to change color balances to
black and white to adding film grain
over the top of the screen it just
created for some really great moments
that as you would share those amongst
each other you would be like wow how did
you make that happen the same thing was
very true like after we released the
game and I remember scrolling through
Twitter and looking at posts that users
had made and be like what game is that
oh wait wait that's the game that I just
worked on for so long okay that's pretty
cool talking about you know some of the
Colossus and you know the unique
challenges that every single one of them
provide we would we would take time to
go to the the ps2 version of the game
and extract all of the assets the models
the animations the skeletons and pull
those out of the original and use those
as the baseline for the ps4 version and
so one of the main things that our
animators would do would go through and
increase the bone counts on the
characters to basically create more
realistic motion in them
this guy was interesting because inside
of the code all of the bones were very
hard coded that there were exactly this
number of bones and then physics
deformation would basically be applied
to the bones to sort of get the up and
down swimming motion through this
Colossus has as it flies through the sky
and so things as simple as we would like
to add additional bones to increase the
fidelity of animation
and initially from engineering I would
say that it's absolutely acceptable
let's do that that sounds like a great
thing to do to the next day pulling up
the game and realizing that this colossi
is completely screwed and is in a ball
floating around in the sky how could you
foresee that it's been a decent amount
of time as well just like quality of
life sort of stuff
taking the bow aiming and improving it
so that it felt like it was a little
more fluid a little more natural well at
the same time we didn't want to change
it so it wasn't recognizable we made
changes such as changing the animations
if you if you play the game and notice
in the original ps2 version the
bowstring is always on the outside of
wanderer's arm well as we started
playing the game and you start looking
at details and paying attention to
what's actually going on you're like
it's actually quite awkward like nobody
actually carries a bow like that
so we reworked all of the animations
associated with the bow to basically
rework it so that the string is on the
inside of the arm so it's much more
natural to how an individual would
actually carry a bow I think Shadow has
taught me that once it comes out that's
really what you're gonna care about is
how much attention to detail did you
spend and how much care and love did you
actually put into it and so as I move
forward personally I want to make sure
that I'm putting in that that extra
little bit of love that extra little bit
of care paying a little bit more
attention to some of the more my new
details or quality of life things so
that when I'm looking at our game a year
after it's been released I can still
hold it up and say yes I did my absolute
best work there
[Music]